30 minute workouts
20 minute recipes 10 minute mindfulness
ready to become
get filled on the app store or google
play i'm joanna saw and today's workout
is going to be a 15 minute express
morning workout i'm a believer that a
short workout is better than no workout
so if you know that you're going to have
a busy day ahead start your morning with
this workout okay and i promise you you
will start your day feeling really
strong and energized only 15 minutes
let's do this
[Music]
there will be a total of seven exercises
to work on your total body and you don't
need a lot of space for this workout
okay so the first workout is going to be
a sumo squat and a reach what i want you
to do is stand really wide with your
knees and toes pointed out and just take
it easy okay because it's the morning
time and i just want you to feel your
muscles lengthening so just reach down
squat down tap down and reach up all
right let's go so tap down and reach up
nothing vigorous in the morning i'm not
going to do some crazy high intensity
workout
this is to really
wake
every single muscle in your body out and
also to give you the energy you need for
the rest of your day so squat
and reach up stretch up feel your back
being stretched out
feel your glutes your legs
and remember do not collapse your knees
inwards okay so reach up
tap down
keep your back straight chest up and
look straight ahead good stretch up
good
very good tap and stretch
and keep going feel more each time you
go squat deeper very good all right
so we are going to work a little bit on
our core as well
lunge with knee driver step forward with
your toes pointer forward and shoulder
width apart alright so take a step back
on your right leg and i want you to just
reach
your knees up all right so step up and
down if you need to you can place both
hands in front of you for balance so we
want to wake the core muscles up as well
up point just working on your right leg
point
good as high as you can
point feel your right glutes
keep going
step back
making sure both knees
are in a 90 degree position step
and point up
and down good nice and controlled
do not rush through the workout
step back
up
down
up
and shake it out on the second round we
will be working on your left side all
right low square walk this is going to
burn okay so again
stand slightly wider than shoulder width
apart get into a low squat and all i
want you to do is imagine you're drawing
a square okay so step forward
and step back that's it while
maintaining a low position throughout
so it's going to really burn on your
thighs as well as your glutes step
forward step back do not come up
feel the burn
feel your muscles waking up
it's going to be a great and awesome
morning step forward
back
forward
and back okay pushing through your heels
stay low stay with me
you're almost there only 10 seconds left
feel the burn
and we will be working on some upper
body after this
last one
forward
and ah
shake it out okay
next workout okay step right at the edge
of your mat is going to be inch worm to
push up all right so what i want to do
is keeping your legs straight slowly
inch forward
feel the stretch on your hamstrings into
a plank give me one push-up and slowly
inch back
while keeping your legs straight okay
feel the stretch on the hamstring stand
up
again
down
inch forward
into a plank
push up
and back
very good
and now back up
down again
if you have to you can bend your knees
slightly okay
and into a plank and push up
and slowly inch back
very good one more
inch forward
nice strong push-up
and
inch back all right just shake it out
okay now let's lie down on your mat okay
hip thruster
place your hands right beside you
heels close to your butt and just lift
your glutes off the floor squeeze it
lower it down slightly engage your hips
and get your glutes and squeeze it very
good okay hold it for two counts right
at the top and lower it back down
imagine there's a string pulling your
belly and your hips straight up
very good squeeze it's all about muscle
engagement release
up and squeeze good
if you have a bed what you can do is
place both feet on your bed
and perform this workout it is going to
be more challenging back down
up
feel your hip flexors opening up as well
up
good back down and just relax okay
next
workout we're going to work on your core
alright so it's going to be alternating
leg raise again i want you to aim to
keep your legs straight alright so let's
start on your left leg stretch it feel
the stretch on the hamstrings stretch it
feel the crunch on your core at the same
time reach stretch point your toes
reach and stretch good
let's keep moving let's not stop right
now
feel the crunch on your upper and lower
abs
try to reach your ankles if you can't
just reach
the back of your knees to begin with all
right stretch
pointing your toes
stretch
look straight ahead
nice and controlled
don't just drop your legs nice and
control stretch it out
good
feeling the stretch on your back as well
very good all right now
let's get up and perform
a short cardio blaster okay
your favorite mountain climber alright
so let's get into a high plank position
let's start slow okay so drive your knee
close to your chest
all right
keeping
a flat and firm plank do not pike your
butt up if you see yourself doing this
this is wrong
so flat back
and now let's bring the speed up
into a running mountain climber good
keep going
breathe in and breathe out
very good
you are strong and you will get a short
one minute break after this 10 more
seconds
keep climbing
last few more
strong speed it up
last three more
and just drop
and get into a child's pose
take this time to breathe
bring your heart rate down a little bit
and we want to repeat the entire circuit
once more right so just get into a plank
let's just do a little bit of stretching
get into a plank
into cobra
and into downward
dog
stretch it out again plank
cobra
and
downward
dog
very good all right
that was seven minutes you have another
seven minutes okay
this time i want you to give your best
effort okay you should be sweating by
now okay let's start standing wide knees
pointed out toes pointed out sumo squat
with reach okay if you want to you can
get onto your toes and squeeze your
calves as well reach remember the goal
is to drive your butt down alright reach
it's not about bending forward drive
your glutes down
tap feel the stretch on your inner
thighs and reach tap through the stretch
on the inner thighs and outer glutes
and reach good nice keep going reach
tap down reach tiptoe very good
long
and strong good
keep going reach lengthen the spine
nice one more reach
lengthening and good all right
lunge with knee drive okay so step
forward we've worked on our right leg
now let's work on our left side okay so
step your right leg back ready let's go
step your right leg back
and drive your right knee
straight up okay
lunge as low as you can find your
balance
tighten your car suck your belly in look
straight ahead
very good
it's time to work on the left
glute
nice
drive it pushing through your heels okay
so
chest up
keeping
your back
straight
nice drive it up as high as you can up
good let's challenge yourself up
find that balance
a few more
down
up
and ah
that left thighs okay
your favorite low square walk okay so
step back
stand slightly wider than shoulder width
apart and i challenge you to stay low
throughout let's go down
forward and back good
forward and back
nice okay
feel
the tension
on your glutes
your hamstring as well as your quads
very good
keeping your chest up and your back flat
okay do not hunch or collapse forward
stay up
pushing your butt back
very good
keep going you're halfway there
feel the burn i feel you it's the
morning
but we want to kick-start our metabolism
let's go
a few more
stay low
forward last one
and ah check it out okay
let's step
towards the back of our mat insurance to
push up okay so this time aim to keep
your legs straight and stretch your
hamstrings ready slowly inch forward
nice push-up
as low as you can up
slowly inch back while still keeping
your legs straight
and come back up good
again
inch if you can't do a full push-up then
you can always start on your knees
alright and slowly inch back
and step up very good
if you are halfway through
push up
slowly inch back do not rush i want you
to feel the stretch on your hamstrings
activate that muscle
and now
the strength will be from your chest and
your shoulders slowly inch back
and you're done okay let's get down onto
the mat
hip thruster okay if you have a higher
platform then place both legs on a
higher platform to challenge yourself
even more okay keep your heels close to
your butt and now let's go up
and back down control it
up squeeze for two counts and down okay
if you don't hold it right at the top it
will not be as effective come up
back down
and really push it squeeze your core as
well back down
and up good
if you want to you can also do
single leg hip thruster okay
up
and down
up squeeze on your right side down and
now let's change
up
down
focusing on your left glutes
up
back down and just
take a moment to breathe
alternating
leg raise okay so
lengthening your entire body
with your legs straight let's crunch up
and reach
good
crunch up and reach
toes pointed straight
to the ceiling
up
okay lift your shoulders off the floor
very good
point
hold it for one count and release
try to reach as far as you can
good
back down
pointed very good
breathe out
right at the top
breathe in
and breathe out
in
and
out
good last few more
and let's get back up
right guess what you have one more
workout
and let's end it with a mountain climber
okay go as fast as you can only 45
seconds all right let's go high plank
drive your
knees towards your chest
keep climbing
push
into the ground okay
strong solid plank keeping your back
flat
keep driving keep pushing this is your
final 45 seconds and you are done let's
go
climb it
feel your heart raising
push it we want to really increase your
heart rate last 15 seconds
go breathe in and breathe out pace your
breathing last 10 seconds
you're gonna start your day feeling
amazing
a few more
and
hear that buzzer
that's a sign that you are
done okay so before we go off let's just
take a moment
to bring our heart rate back down and
stretch okay
so get into a child's pose
just breathe
don't rush through your morning okay
you don't have to be anywhere right now
you don't have to go anywhere
it's only 50 minutes
of the time back to yourself okay
this is your time
and this is all that matters
stretch
look at me
if you are sweaty just like me then let
me know in the comments below and give
this video a thumbs up i'm ready to get
into the shower and start my day feeling
really strong and remember a short
workout is better than no workout
do this workout first thing in the
morning and you will thank yourself for
it remember to also check out my other
workout videos workout challenges
healthy recipes nutritional tips and do
hit the subscribe button and most
importantly is to turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time i upload a new video
all the best and i will see you in my
next sweaty session